هانتر بايد النجل الرئيس الامريكي وحاسبه
الشخصيه قصه المهمه لاكثر من 66 في المئه
من الامريكيين تفاصيل القصه تعود الى
ابريل 2019 حاسوب شخصيه
الاصلاح بعد اكثر من عام ونصف من الحادثه
وقبل اسابيع على الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك يثير قضيه
وجدلا كبيره التقرير كشف عن بيانات وصور
ووثائق ماليه عثر عليها داخل الحاسوب
الشخصي تعود لهنتربوينت ووفقا للتقرير
حينها سلطت الرسائل الضوء على كيفيه
استخدام نجل الرئيس نفوذه سياسي في ممارسه
اعمال في دول اخرى وخصوصا في اوكرانيا
والصين اليوم ماسك تويتر
الشخصي الى دائره الضوء من جديد ما حدث مع
قصه اخفاء تويتر
على تويتر في الخامسه مساءا بالتوقيت
الشرقي
وثلاثون تغريده معززه بالروابط والصور غرد
بها الصحفي الامريكي ماتيبي ونشرها مالك
تويتر
احدى التغريدات تحدثت عن تفاصيل التقرير
الذين نشارته صحيفه نيويوركوس عام 2020
التغريده اوضحت ان اداره تويتر حينها قامت
باتخاذ خطوات غير مسبوقه لاخفاء القصه
وازاله الروابط ونشر تحذيرات بانها قد
تكون غير امنه تغريده اخرى تحدثت عن اداره
تويتر وتعاملها مع التغريدات وذكرت انه في
عام 2020 كانت الطلبات التي تاتي الى
تويتر بحذف التغريدات تعتبر امرا روتينيه
وانه عندما كان يكتب احد المديرين
تنفيذيين في تويتر الى اخر حول تغريده
معينه لمراجعتها من فريق بايرن ثم يصله
الرد تم التعامل معها
تغريدات وملفات تويتر حظيت فور صدورها
تفاعلا كبيرا على منصه وطرح التساؤلات عن
اساليب السلطات الامريكيه خاصه من ممثل
حزب الديمقراطي بممارسه الرقابه على تويتر
وازاله التغريدات
ملوك الشيخ العربيه